françois mitterrand en visite au centre
georges pompidou fut inauguré tout à
l'heure les nouveaux aménagements du
musée d'art moderne il fallait il
trouver plus de place pour exposer les
nouvelles toiles acquise depuis quelques
années véronique bonnet sept ans après
son inauguration on refait l'aménagement
intérieur du centre pompidou et cela
peut choquer pour un musée qui nous
semble encore tout neuf
pourtant manque de place manque de
lumière des cimaises trop mobile qui
s'harmonisait bien avec l'architecturé
extérieure mais qui à l'usagé pour
l'équipe des conservateurs manquer de
cohérence tous les musées se renouvelle
tous les dix ans à peu près même le
louvre si vous situer sur les salles de
la peinture française il ya qu ont été
refaits dans les années 60 on est en
train de les renouveler de les repenser
dû réaménager
parmi les nouvelles acquisitions qui
justifie ce réaménagement des oeuvres
qui manquait cruellement
ainsi c'est toi de nicolas de staël des
pôles plaît aussi les musées français en
posséder très peu deux ou trois ou
encore ceux mandrillon new york city
n'en bowe a négocié pendant plus de 3 de
l'ombre les indications c'était une
carde avoir des espaces de présentation
plutôt que des salles comme pas beaucoup
ce terme
pour un parcours principal quel parcours
majeur qui correspond à la voie royale
du 20e siècle
accompagné de petits espaces
complémentaires dans lesquels on peut
mettre tout ce fourmillement ce
foisonnement de recherche a été bâtie
avec ses salles l'innovation des
messages qu'il fait lire goji par
l'oeuvre qui n'existe sans doute pas
avant puisque pour l'essentiel on peut
dire que la présentation était une
création assez classique avec tableaux
sculptures et nous avons pu rajouter
grâce aux espaces aux lentilles à créer
cet apport pédagogique cette base de la
pédagogie qui accompagne mes oeuvres